I have a lot of haters enemies
Dylan hacker leafy King star they're all
out to destroy me but there's one dare I
even say it man we stronger than all of
these combined his name is Malcolm 1466
why does he hate me I hate it but he's
filled with more hatred than Hitler was
for the Jews he did by working for new
money he's filled with more hatred than
keemstar is too unbiased news reporting
soon all right now I'm at the point
where I don't know what to do anymore
but it seems like he disappeared
Malcolm 1466 where are you
I've searched the internet for an answer
from the farthest east to the north east
west
Malcolm videos are nowhere to be found
why is this why need answers
where is he what is this a shed of hope
the truth about Malcolm
46 times
DJ viola
DJ the reasons to hate PewDiePie the
reason why I hate P what the [ __ ]
happened
the reason why I hate people oh my god
you are no Malcolm you sound different
why do you look different
why is he wearing his skin oh one he's
always on my victory page I am always on
his what page
oh my victory page well if I'm always on
your recommended patient maybe that's
because you watched my videos open
YouTube I see painted part just stupid
[ __ ] don't call me a [ __ ] cuz you're a
[ __ ] - [ __ ] haha two - number two he's
fuzz my eyes are so ridiculous okay
hmm Falcon or for example he knows about
the PewDiePie reference s Malcolm you
love me
say it you watch my videos you know my
references what else is there stop
pretending dude I have mall stash but
you don't give a [ __ ] did he just say
did he thank you did he just say he has
more sash and he doesn't give a [ __ ]
it's been great thank you
Malcolm wins Malcolm wins
that is a [ __ ] night stash for an
eight-year-old the most important part
the most important part here comes okay
pewdiepie is gay
oh no 50 parties gay
I can't to real piggies build a pig 50
pig is a [ __ ] what am i what am i
what am I
you can't just exit the video right
there what am I tell you what I don't
know
wait what the [ __ ] is this
how far amia greenbox concept why am I
watching this oh my god
it's Malcolm but Malcolm you're too
young too drab go Malcolm go whoa
he's right he is much cooler yeah what
is he doing how is Malcolm in an Alfa
Romeo commercial and I'm not welcome or
DJ via luck or whatever your name is
I'm gonna send you a message check it
out I'm calling you
check out the message and reply all
right guys we've had a lot of fun with
my phone a lot of fun I don't want it to
be too far I don't want anyone to go and
harass this kid I don't want anyone who
happened to find his identity to do
anything to even look for it all right
we made up the name Malcolm because we
didn't want people to find his identity
and we didn't want people harassing him
I just think his videos is hysterical I
think is a funny personality and I would
love to have him featured on my channel
Malcolm DJ Vala
bad luck I've been trying to reach you
I'm gonna write your message on YouTube
Twitter check your Facebook I found you
everywhere all right I would love to
have you on the PewDiePie channel I get
if you're not interested and to all my
brothers don't harass this guy it's it's
not it's not cool I'm never into that I
just reacted the videos if I see any one
of you harassing bullying whatever
you're at all right that's it for this
video if you enjoyed watching please
leave a like thank you so much hopefully
we can get DJ Baylock
or Malcolm his real name is Malcolm on
that on the PewDiePie channel I would
love to fly them over to UK I don't know
that's all for me for now and as always
stay awesome breasts from the rocky
shores of Hawaii
really really this would kill me for
years I would have to go to therapy
are you serious from the rocky shores to
Hawaii to the beaches of Hawaii are you
serious how are you not destroyed